This is a beautiful auction room,
ladies and gentlemen, I
warmly welcome you to
our second auction out of this
world, I am pleased to be able to hold it with you,
we
organized it together with Christian Link
from the Wunderkammer that was Echo before the
auction  Huge, especially
Trinity's exhibition in the
gym has far exceeded all expectations.
We had over
30,000 people come to see Trinity in the last
two weeks. It was
wonderful to see all the
children's eyes shining when they saw
a real T-Rex for the first time  I have
seen the skeleton here is a small part
of it you can only now see how big it
is
I would also like
to thank the team at Jakob and Jolanda
Siebertalmuseum
and Dinosaur Museum Aathal at the beginning of this auction. It is worth
going there at the moment  There is
also
an exhibition about T-Rex parallel to our exhibition and auction, so
I would like to thank you very much, you
are here, we would never have managed all of this without you,
I have a
big request
if you bid, please bid with the
yellow piece of paper from this side too
because that's a bit like
that now I'm starting a start with lot
number no
that's a medical
head model and I start at 500
I have 600 a written start
600 francs is six for me or
600 francs is offered for me
on  Pool
he understood that on the Internet so
then we do 600 on the Internet and I
do 650 on mine that's maybe
easier 650 francs is an order for me
650 francs
650 Swiss friends 700 online 700 francs
is on the Internet firstly secondly
no one more than  750 online
750 francs is online 700 and fifty
Fracks 750 francs for the first
750 francs for the second and 800
online 800 francs is offered
800 francs 800 francs for the first
again online 800 francs for the first
800 francs for the second and 900
900 is online 900 900  and we are waiting
for the next bid from the Internet 900
francs 900 francs for the first 900
francs for the second and for and over
1000 francs 1000 francs you can also bid
on the first one you can also
bid on the first one, it's not just on the
third one so we're at 1000  Francs
online 1,000 francs for the first and 1100
francs many thanks to the Internet
1100 francs 1100 francs 1 2 and
again let
's have a chance last chance 11012
3 1100 francs that goes to a bidder
on the internet that's number 3
wonderful
we're coming to loud 9002
a big one  Murder clam
in the Pacific
1940 I'm starting here with
700 francs telephones we have wonderful
800 francs online
800 francs is online 900 francs is
on the phone at Mr. der Corso 900
francs is offered
900 and I have 1000 with me a
written order 1000 francs
1100 francs please  Years 1100 francs
1100 1200 is 1,200,300 for me
in the middle of the hall
1300 is for me
1,400 francs is offered 1500 on the
phone 1,600 at your point
1600 francs is offered 1700
1800 francs
1800 francs 1900 please years and 2000
bread watch
2000 francs en 22  my order is over
2200 francs here on the phone
2200 francs
for the first when the normal
2200 francs for the second and
never one two and
three
2200 francs on the phone
with the bidder number 90 92
you can hear me now it's
better so
verruz
okay wonderful so  we come to
9003 lot 900 and free a trilobits
350 million years old found in the
USA here I start with 1400 francs
1500 is already offered for me 1600
1700 francs is for me at the pool
1,800 francs
1800 francs for the first thousand 1900
francs 2000 Frankenhausen
2000  Francs for 1
2000 francs for the second and 2200
francs is for me
2,400 2000 before 100 for the first second
and never the
third time
2400 should before 2000 before 100
90 30
lot no oh before Coco de Mar Seychelles
519 50
telephones thank you very much I'll start with 800
I have a lot of orders with
me 900,000 11 12 13
1600 francs
10006007009
1000 1000 1900 francs and 2000 telephones 2000 francs
Dominik Frau 2000
francs first in 2000 francs second and to no one
more than
20012 and
3000 sold answer the phone at 90 68
Number 905
this is a hand-signed
photo by Meiko Collins and I'm starting
here with 700 francs. I also have
a lot of orders here. You all have
wonderful phones so 800 900,000 11 12 1300
francs is for me one
10003,300,400 francs for Stefan
w1000500 francs is here
1500 francs 1600 francs
1600 francs 1600 francs 1600 1700 can
I say
1700 francs is at my table
1700 1800 spectators a thousand francs
100 2000 too acts
2200 francs can I say
200200 2,400
2400 francs here on the phone
2400 francs
24 00 francs for the first
2,400 francs for the first  second and
third time sold for
2400 on the phone
for the 9070 thanks Stefan
London 100 and6
100 million year old ammonite I
start with
1600 francs
1600 for lot 99
a
2000 francs
2200 francs is here
2400 francs is here
2600 francs is 100 for me in
2006  2016
3000 francs
3000 francs 3000 3000 francs for the
first, second and
third time 3000 francs goes to the
bitor with the 90 91
not no oh 7
is dedication with Alex and Humboldt
a handwritten dedication by
Humboldt was published in 1950 55
I start with 1600 francs
online
2000 francs is online I can
sell it for 2000 francs
someone would like to offer a little more this
is a hero of
natural science and natural history
2000 francs
2000 francs that would be a
small
souvenir of this auction in 2000 for the
first time in
2002 and for the
third time
2000 francs on  Internet
980 no
these go-kart stones that were found
near fontenblau already
luigiators had great fun with
these crazy
shapes and decorated half the
castle park with them I start
with 4500 francs before
1000500
francs and 5000 is offered
5000 francs whistles 1000 5000 francs
5000 francs
for the first
5000 francs for the second time more one
two and
three
5000 5000 francs goes to the Beata 20
we come to number 999
Switzerland
1990 she died of natural causes in the
zoo and was prepared for posterity
so everything was
handled fairly  have a lot of phones,
thank you very much and I start with 1,500
francs 1,000,500 stop quickly Steffi
question who has it
so then I offer 1,600 francs for the person
on the phone who can't be reached
1,600 1,700 francs then 1,700 at
klaristik
1,800 at Christian 1900 1900
2000 thousand spectators they are allowed  Also
bidding in room 22 again Laura
2200 francs
2400 previously 2400 francs is here
2600 Laura 2626
.600
impressively beautiful animal 3000 francs 3000
3000 francs is online I think
33 Christian
33500 here on the phone 3535
3500 francs
3500 francs is born
if he doesn't go any further  That's always the case,
you still have to offer a little
if you're not sure
38 so 3800 online
4000 they're doing it right here 4000
4000 francs
before 1000 4000 francs for the first
4000 francs for the second and always
more than 4,000
2 and
should be before  1000 4000 francs
to the 90 64
[music]
which crashed over
Weinberg a community in Switzerland about 200,000 years ago
has evaporated into a few pieces and our piece was
found on May 6th 2017 and I start with
3200 francs
3000200 francs who  says more than 32
3400 francs and 3600 francs 3600 francs 3800 francs 3800 francs 3000
122000 francs
4000 francs for the first time
for the second more and more and for the
third time
1000 can I see your number again
please that was a little quicker
thank you that brings luck  151
we come to the number
911 lot no
so call space suits I start at 50
thousands 50,000 francs for this
space suit and
55,000 francs again Laura 55
55,000 francs is here
55,058,000 francs
88,000 francs is offered 58 and 60,000
francs again Laura 6000 60,000
6 000  Francs for the first
60,000 francs for the second and for one,
two and
three
60,000 francs that goes to the
31 thank you very much
the 912 are 250 to 70 million year
old septarians Belgium
quite one two interesting formations
of nature I'm starting here with 1800
francs 2000 francs is already  offered
22224 26 on the phone 28 at my pool
280028300 francs here
3800 francs is here in the hall
3800 in front of 1000 500
5,000 francs on the phone
500s and
sold 5000 5000 francs on the phone
for the 90 32 thank you very much
thank you
a
command capsule  from Apollo 11 in a small
format hand signed by Butz
Aldrin you know the one I start with
1200 francs one 1000 200
francs
1200,000
300,400 with me ampult one
10400500
1500 francs is in the hall
1500 francs
500 1500 francs for the first second and
for
you have it thank you very much  keep so
1500 francs can I
see the number again please
thank you very much 74
[music]
the so-called anvil
Hendrik Meteorit
I start with 1600 francs wall exchange
600 forlots no on ore 1000 dates
2000 francs 200,000
francs 1 2 and
22 thank you very much
2200 francs 200
2200 francs  1 2 and 3 for the 74 thank you very much
according to 915
the exorcist
these are two
plaster masks from Linda Blair used in the production
and a hand signed photo
I start with 1600 francs
1600 before the exorcist
as he tells me as 1600 francs
1600 1600 1700 1800 francs
1800 francs
1800 francs 1 2 and always more than 1800
then we come to the next number which
is 916
so a bit of a late bid but
we take the
1900 for three okay
not nine one six Slot 96 collection
56000 phones you all have a
thousand francs
2500 2800 francs 3000 francs 3000 3000
francs 3000 3000 francs do you want on the
phone 3000 for the first to the second and
for
one two and three 3000 francs sold
to the bidder 9061
lot 97
a base glove from cosmonaut Anton
in use and I'm starting with 6000
francs a strong one
16,000 francs 6 five
6000500
telephones do you have
90 20 telephone number
we are at 6,500 francs
6000500 600056,800
francs 6a
6,800 francs for the first
6,800 francs for the second and for
sexuality 7000 online 7000 7000
7000 francs is online for the first for the
second
third time 7000 7000 francs for them
90-2020
Golf on the moon Alan Shepherd a
signed golf ball from the first
astronaut to play golf on the moon,
although I think the golf ball
itself wasn't up but he did
sign it and I'm starting here with
500 francs
500 600 700 all with me  Bids
700 8
00 900 900 francs
900 francs 900 who wants to play golf on the moon
900 francs for the first 900 francs for the
second and 1000 Frankenhausen 1000
francs 1000 francs for the first for the
second and for
31,000 francs goes to the 90 and 70
we come  to 919
a bell mask that's more
of Christian Linkhaus's specialty from
me
but it's cool 1200 francs who
offers 1,200 francs 1,200
francs
1,200 I can give it 1200 francs
1,200
1,200 thank you very much 1,300 francs
1,300 francs for the first, for the second and for the
third time
1,300 for  the
90 45
number 920
also something exciting that is a
Batmobile markets from 1989
used in the Batman film and I start
here with
4,200 francs before 1,000
[music]
4800 francs
4,800 francs for the first second and for the
last chance
4812 and 4800
then come  let's go to 9001
that's a huge
Apatosaurus vertebra Jurassic 150 million
years old I start with 7500 francs
7000500 francs
58000 8000 francs 8000 8000 francs 8,300 8,500 francs 8500
francs
8500 francs for the first
8,500 francs for the second more and more
8512 and more and more then we come to
lot
a huge
the product bone also around
150 million years old
Wyoming USA
5500 and 6000 francs 6000
6000 francs and
6,500 francs is 7000 francs 7000 77000
8000 francs 1,000 1,000 8,000 francs
is offered E1000 8000 francs for the
first 8 5 9 10,000 10,000
francs  was born
10,000 they saw him he is so
big
is an order at my pool 10,000
10,000 francs for the first do you
also want to take a small step such a
big bone a small step no
longer 10,000 francs for the first
ten thousand francs for the second and for
third time 10,000 francs 10,000 goes
to the 90
99 thank you
the 93
is a terosaur fossil
very beautifully preserved very rare
fossil that I exclaim with with 60,000
francs 6000 60,000 francs 60,000 francs 60,000
francs 65 70,000 80,000
80,000 francs and 85,000 francs
85,000 francs at 85 90,000  Francs
90,000
and 95 thank you very much no the five start
95,000
90,000 francs and 100,000
100,000 francs
again
for the first safe second and
third time sold for 100,000 francs
to the 90 99
lots no too for the first man in the
moon a wonderful one  Poster
from 1964
you have to have it and that's why I ask
200 francs
300 online 400 I say 500 500 600 francs
600 francs at Christian 600 francs
I leave it to you 600 francs 600 francs
for the first
700 700
dusse 700 francs is with them 700
francs for the first  700 francs for the
second and more and more 700 francs 1
2 and
congratulations warmly 700 francs for the
103 thank you very much
we come to the number
lot 9205
I started
18000 francs 18,000
Frankenthal
okay my daughter asks me if I
want a Red Bull I fall asleep
no  So 20,000 20,000 20,000
francs 20,000 francs here is
20,000
20,000 francs firstin
20,000 francs for the second and 22,000 22,000
francs for the first for the second
and for the third time with reservation
with reservation for the 90-20
to lot 926
a
xenomorph alien i i
translate that  Not you all see that
in the catalog
of course from the 1986 film Aliens,
you can but you I start with
3,200
francs we offer
200 francs
3200 francs
I give with three two 321
3,500 online
third time
3000500 online thank you
no to seven
that's also  in connection with
the film Alien 1978 a
color control print by
allergy sufferers 500 francs 600 700 700
francs is offered 700 700 francs 800
francs 900 francs
1000 which is
950 francs in the hall for the first to the
second and to thank you very much
a thousand thousand should fight a little
You still have
francs but of course I'll give it to you
a thousand francs for the first
a thousand francs for the second and
no one anymore
thank you very much for that is that the 66 or
99 the 66 thank you very much 66 and that was
928 lot no two eight
spixie ananite
129 to  132 million years old
Alb of
France 7000 francs many people 7000
7000 francs who says more than 7000
80008000 8000 francs is offered
8000800085000 francs thank you 10,000
10,000 francs 10,000
10,000 francs for the first 10 and 11 ,000
11,000 with them 11,000 francs their
life 1000 12,000 12,000 francs
12,000 12,000 first the second and to
they were always one two and three
12,000 francs goes to the bidder 90-30
not no to no wonderful
Fossil wood to 10020
millions old Arizona USA 10,000 francs 10,000
beautiful piece 10,000 11,000 12,000
francs 12,000
12,000 francs is already  offered 12,000
12,000 francs
12,000 francs for the first
13 is already on the phone
14,000 with you 14,000
phone is no longer
good for you 14,000
no it's wonderful don't let yourself be
put off 14 15,000 now I've been
taking too long, sorry 15,000
15,000
15,000 francs
for the first to the second and to
finish
is still the hammer one two
and
three 15,000 francs 15,000 very very
nice
for which bitter number
90 32
the 930
that is the big shape open your
rhinosaurus
80,000
what does the phone say no title
90,000 francs  on the phone
19,0000
francs is in the hall
110,000 francs
110,000 francs is here in the hall
1,00010,000 francs for the first to the
second and to the
173 for 110,000
we come to loud 931 lot no three
one
a 200 to 2 to 300,000 year old
mammoth tooth or 2  and I start with
2200 francs 200 Swiss friends 2200
francs
222400 francs
2400 francs 1 2 and more and more 2
400 tuffor
1 2 and more and more 24
3 times
2400 francs
This is an Apollo 7 fabric mission
emblem that is on board the Apollo 7 in
space  I start with 1800 I
have a bid of 2000 francs
2000 francs a bid at my table
ingredients and I can give it with 2000
francs
for the first, second and
third time 2000 francs that goes to the
bidder 90 76
that's a  original NASA terrestrial globe
for 1400
Frankenhausen ago 100,000 500,000 600
1,600 francs
1,600 1600
francs 1600 francs 1 2 and
3600 francs goes to the 9041
we come to the number 934 Lotte 91
photograph from Charles Lindberg 1930 1940
I started 2000 200 0 francs
2000 2,200 francs
2400 francs
2400  Franken is born 200
francs for the first
2400 francs for the second and
third time
2400 for the 9045
we come to lot number 935
a gold nugget Victoria Australia
of course with analysis and so on
telephones thank you very much I start at
90,000 francs
90,000 90,000 francs
95,00,000 in  Hall one dog
100,000 francs is here 110,000 francs
is on the phone 120,000
francs is in the piss when do
we have the twenty towns
130,000 is on the phone 125
of course 125,000
francs is here one dog
130,000
[music]
130,000 francs
to the second
and to the
yes no 130,000 what  he has to convert
euros is the same one two and
three 100 thank you very much
130,000 for the 96
thank you
postcard
nineteen thirty and I started
5000500
6000 francs and I have a bid for
6500 francs with me
6500 francs was born
6:5500 francs someone more than
656512 and no one else
6,500 1 2 and
6,500 francs thank you very much and I go
to number 937 according to no 37
that's something wonderful, that's
Eddie Merckx's bike
that he rode
in the Tour de France and or in the Giro
d'Italia in 1974  is and I start
here with 9000 francs 9000
12000 online 12,000 12,000
13,000 francs
13,000 14,000
francs
14,000 15,000 15,000
15,000 16,000 is online 6000 online
thank you 17,000 18.
000 on the phone online
I take a sip of water
they already have one from Eddie Merckx
from 74
and orange
So 18,000 I don't want to bother you
18,000 francs they're ready outside
18,000 francs for the first to the second
and for someone else
10012 and 3 18 are thank you very much 18,000
francs to Peter online
we come to the number 9381
so I'm not offering you offers 800
900000  For me, francs are one
1000, 11200 francs thank you very much 1400
francs
1500 francs telephone
1700 francs 1800 in the hall
1,800 francs is in the salt 2000 is
online
2000 francs 200,000
francs for the first
2000 francs for the second
22 would be nice yes
2000 francs
so because of a hundred francs  If you do
n't stop he or she will regret it forever
2000 francs 2000 last chance 1 2 and
3 thank you very much for bidding
2000 francs 2000 online thank you very
much thank you very much
the 939
francs 2800 francs 2 8 2 8 2 9 3000
300012 does
anyone want to bid?
then we go to 940
its is a prototype of a
space glove for the mars program
1200 francs warm 1000 two 100 one 1000
for
1000500 all bids at my table 1500
how much
one
81800 francs is later years 1800
francs
1800 that's a stupid microphone
1800 francs is offered here
1800 francs for the first, second and
third time
1800 francs
for whom
no
thank you for
the next poster
is great Robinson Crusoe on
Mars Robinson Cruiser on the Mars
pictures
nineteen sixty four 400
francs
500 600 francs 600 600  Francs is
offered 600 francs
600 francs for the first second and
always more than 600 I hit with
612 and
3,600 francs goes to the 90 88
so loudly no for two is one of the ten a
biggest mores maturites in private hands
also one of the  largest Mars meteorites in
private Hans the Red Colossus
we have the phones 1 2 3 thank you very much
I start with
120,000.125,000
125/130,000 thank you very much
130,000
140,000 francs
140,000 francs is offered I can sell it
140,000 francs for the first
140,000
francs for the second
and for the
120,000 francs
and we go to 903
this is a globe of the red planet
Mars that I call out with 2000 francs
I have a lot of orders here so
two two five two eight three three five
4000 francs all bids at my
table before 1.4000 francs is born  before
1000 4000 francs before 1000 4000 4000
francs before a thousand someone more one
two and
three 4000 francs before 1000 salt to nine o2
age 90 28
944 is a student mug in the shape of a
devil 650 francs 650
650 francs 650 1 2 and 650 francs a
souvenir 650  Francs
one two and offered many thanks
650 francs for the third time 650 for the
90 75
945 that is an
elephant bird egg
that I can proclaim with
14,000 francs before 10,000 francs for lot
945 14,000 14,000 15,000 16,000 16,000
francs offered table 16,000
francs 6,000 16,000
17,000 francs
70,000  Francs 17,000 francs for the first,
for the second
and for the thank you very much 17,000
the 946 is a crino
very decorative
that I exclaim with 10,000 francs
10,000 10,000 10,000 11,000 12,000
francs 12,000 13,000 13,000 14,000 14.0 00 15,000 15
16,000 17,000 19,000
19,000 francs is offered
19,000 francs for the first  Second and
for the
third time more than 19,000 19,000 francs for the third time,
with
the number 9003
number 947
a devil shooting disc USA
for 3000 francs 3000 3,000
francs 3335 is offered
353538 thanks
3800 4000 is on the phone
4000  1000
for the first, second and
third time before 1,4000 francs on the
phone please call
90 89
89 or 98 98
and we get to the number 948
a megalodon tooth Georgia USA
5 million years old
lots of orders I start with 2000
francs to 1,000
francs 22  first in the hall then my
birth is at 24 so not mine but
one at the table
2400 francs
2500 francs
2500 francs is offered here
2500 francs coincidence 25
00 francs for the first
for the second me oh no 27
that's 300 francs more you can
save the next ones
Definitely not 10 years and they don't feel a
bit sorry no
and not a step more okay so
2700 francs online one two and three
2,700 francs but I think
that's online I think there's
another one
so the 949 a second megalodon tooth
also 5  Million years old
that is also a bit more expensive
225335 4000 francs is at my table
4000 4000 4000 francs is offered before
1000 for the first second and
finished online number 14
3 4000 francs
goes to the 90 85
lot 950 a narwhal tusk
start here  I we have telephones
thank you very much I start with 10,000
francs 10,000 10,000 francs who tells
me as 10,000
11,000 12,000 12,000 francs on the
other hand 13,000 online 13,000
1400014 10,000 francs 15,000 is 15,000 for me For me,
15 is
15,000 16 online 6000 online
16,000 francs
18,000 online
you have to explain it a bit on the
phone how nice it is in your
beautiful Italian
it works
so
18,000 francs for the first
18,000 francs for the second and
third time 18,000 francs 18000 that was
online thank you very much
an iron meteorite found in the campo del siero
in Argentina I start with
3200 francs 3 5 3 8 4 4 5 5000 is
already offered 5000 5000 francs 5000
5500 francs
5500 francs Laura that would be your stake do
you want to offer
6656500 francs 6500
for the first second no one more than
6,500 francs
that's with me
First of all, not with me on
my order
6512 and
6,500 francs goes to 90 85
this is a space helmet signed by Jim Level
Jim Level was
the captain of Apollo 13 and my
family gets angry when I ask
Once again Apollo 13 is
the best, craziest mission there
has ever been, I hope you know it
otherwise you have to read up and
definitely watch the film so
3200 francs 32 francs
3800 francs freak
3.8000 francs I have to
buy now 4000 4000
4000 francs for  first
4000 francs for the second and
third time 4000 francs and we go
to lot
900 and 62
another meteorite from the moon I
start here with
4000 francs before 1000 for lot
962004000
francs 4000 francs 4200
4,200 francs
1 2 and more and more then we come to
lot 963
this is an ansuraptor claw they are
very rare
and I start with 5000 francs 5000
5500 francs is offered 5000 500 francs 5,500 6000 6000
6000 francs is on the phone
600065 6500
francs
6,500 francs and 7000 francs is on the
phone 7000 francs
7000 francs  here is
7000 francs to the first
7000 francs to the second and to
someone more than 7000 francs 1 2 and
7000 francs
964 a wonderful ammonite
71 million years old is views with
18,000 francs 18000
18,000 francs 19,000
20,000 francs is born
22,000
22. 000 francs for the first
22,000 francs for the second and
220012 and 22,000 francs and we come
to lot
according to 965
a Triceratops horn
66 to 68 million years old
trikera tops that is 3 ceratops or
whatever the same time as this T-Rex
I start with 3000 francs tree  1000
33 at the very back a nice
gentleman waves and I say 3 5
3 8 4000 4
5000 55
ready
5500 francs is
5500 francs and 6000 in the middle
6000 look at me and offer them
again no more so 6000  Franken
for the first, second and
third time, thank you very much, may I
see your number please
164 for 6000 thank you 966
a pink spoonbill Switzerland 1990 to
2000 very beautiful bird that I call up
with 1300 francs 1400 1,500 is already
offered 1000500 francs
1500 francs
1500 francs 1600  Francs
1600 francs is in the hall
1,600 1600 francs
1,600 francs for the first second and for
the 74 thank you
photographer at Neil Armstrong Boots Aldrin
and John Glenn
one 1000 600 I have two bids at
2500 francs
two bids at my table that  is
wonderful they solve me
2700 is online 2000 700
700 francs for the first for the second and
for the
third time
2700 francs is online thank you very much
lot 908
is a ship figure 17th century
Sicily
18,000 francs
20,000 francs
20,000 francs is born
22,000 francs at the table
20,000
24,000 francs
the  the spider wants to bid
so
24,000 francs for the first
24,000 francs for the second and
26 thank you very much the spider irritates me
a bit here before my eye then
I can say 28 or I have to
say 28,000 they want 30,000 thank you very much
for the 1000
30,000 francs for that  1000 for the first
second and third time for the 74
thank you very much 30,000
another wonderful poster 969
Barbarella USA 1968
so Barbarella I have 1 2 3 4 5 6
orders for 500 600 700 800,000
francs who can offer a little
more 1,000 francs wandhaus 1000 francs
1000 francs
for the first to the second and for
more and more one 10012 and 3 1,000 francs goes
to the bidder 90 47
a 66 to 68 million year old
this Saurus Rex tooth
which I we have the telephones thank you
very much
4500 francs before 1,000
5,000
5,500
Frankenhausen
seven
8500 francs is still with me
9000 9000 francs is in the hall 9000 9000
10,000 10,000 10,000 francs 10,000
francs 10,000 10,000
10,000 francs for the first
10,000 francs for the second and always
more than 1000012 thank you
10. 000
I know show me your number please
can you tell me yours  Show number thank you
very much for the 97
original signed biography of Yuri
Gagarin
I start with 1800 francs is offered
2500 francs
2500 francs for the first
2500 francs for the second and for
2500 1 2 and
3,400 francs goes to the 90 83
and signs
Portrait
Juri  Gagarin
4505600 francs
600 francs for the first
600 francs for the second and
third time every 600 francs goes to the
90 88
we come to number
973 of the Bubbler Jukebox Wurlitzer USA
1957 an absolute icon
we had the telephone 90 61 so you
offer wonderful then 19 90  74 90 77
We also have these wonderful telephones
I start with 8000 francs 1000 I
would like to play something for you but
it is on the other side 8000 9000
11000 12000
13000 francs is for me
15000 francs is for me
60007000
17000 francs 7000 at 1000 0
18000  Francs is offered
a 10,000
18,000 francs
1812 and
for the 90 61
900 44 a
wonderful bird a
beautiful colored, wonderfully
prepared bird for 2000 francs 2225
2500 francs
2800 francs is offered
2800 francs for the first
2800 francs for the second and for the
third time 2800
then goes the 261
97500 francs
1500 francs
1600 1800
1,800 francs
1800 francs for the first second and
third time 1800
lot 1 7 6
an ammonite trip you are already
115 million years old found in
Morocco and I start with 12,000
francs 12,000 12,000 francs 12,000 12. 000
12,000  Francs 12,000 13,000 14,000
thank you very much for 10,000
14,000 francs 15,000 francs 15,000 15,000
francs 15,000 15,000
francs for the first time for the second
and for the
third time 15,000 francs
and we come to loud 977
the antlers of a giant Irish moose
I begin here with 10,000 francs
10,000 no 77
2014  A thousand cases is everything for me
15,000
15.5 is for me
115,500 francs
15 5 I say 15 15 5 so that you
can say 16,000
they want that
15,500 francs is offered for the first,
second and
third time
15,500 francs goes to the 90
as we come  too loud
978 and I have a very nice announcement here
the company Uhrwerk, their boss Martin freist
present,
has decided to use the profit from the
auction of this watch and we are now
auctioning off a Trinity
hand-painted bronze and black titanium
unique watch with bone material from a
real T-Rex  Well, the Uhrwerk company has
decided to donate the profits
to the
Dinosaur Museum Aathal
for
their further projects and
research work
[applause]
and it's nice that there are people
who support science and the museums
that get to the media
There are a lot more people private collectors who
support museums than people generally
think, but now you have to bid so
I start with
50,000 francs 55 60,000 francs 60,000
60,000 francs 6000 70000
70,000 francs is offered here
75,000
75000780,000 francs please on the phone
eight 5 in Stefan
19000 Franke  please years 19,000
90,000 francs
90,000 francs a watch a T-Rex and
a good deed
90,000 francs
95,000 francs 95,000
95,000 francs is with Stefan
95,000 francs
95,000 a unique item
100,000 100,000 francs here on the phone
one dog
100,000 francs 1
00,000 francs is
100,000 francs for years  first
100,000 francs for the second and the
finished 10000012
[applause]
9 Trinity and we'll show you a very short
film
that's good I
think I can tell you a little
something while this film is
playing here you can see it in the Zurich
gym  I would like to thank the Zurich
Tonhalle very much for
allowing us to set it up there as I said.
15,000 people registered
to watch this wonderful skeleton for 42 hours.
We could have let in a lot more
if we had been allowed to, they say something
like that. There were around 20,000
spectators at the concert  The echo in the gym
was huge.
School classes of children with smiling eyes.
That was wonderful.
As you know, it is only the third
T-Rex skeleton that
has ever been auctioned off
and
we would like to thank
the Saure Museum Aathal for the great
help again for the third time  you have given us there
now like thanks a lots
family seaver and there team from the
Dinosaur Museum in Althaus Zurich who
thinks so much to build
up and down the checks everything
the
Kate and thenity is all so and
companite
a prison
German to the  just so everything is
transparent and clear and
so I think you action
I start with
4 million Swiss francs before
Million swissfranks 4 million before
million for meeting for million and
before million
before 100,000 before million before 100,000
forms
bits and this is also the  resurf
prices 4 million 500,000 francs 4
million 500,000 families
families
4 million 800,000 francs
4 million 800,000 francs is offered
on the phone with Caroline Weser in front of
Million AIDS 100,000
4 million 800,000 francs I can sell 4
million francs
4 million
more than 4 million 800,000 francs for the
first  For the second and
third time, I would like to thank you very much
[applause]
I would like to thank you very much for
coming. It has been a very exciting
and great time the last few months and
weeks, especially the exhibitions in
the Zurich gymnasium if you
have objects that you would like to sell  You
contact us not only trinities and
T-Rex we also auction other things I
wish you a very nice
afternoon a nice evening and look forward
to hearing again next time
[applause]